Welcome to AERA English TV's Native Maestro.
I'm your maitre d' Seita.
And this program is designed to help you become the native maestro.
Today's Maestro Hook.
Maestro Hook is a small conversation hook that you can use with foreigners...
...to kind of get a good conversation going.
So, please use this with a foreigner when you're talking to them.
Today's topic is mistaken identity.
Western people are basically very friendly people.
So, even on the streets,...
...when they see someone that they think they know,...
...they'll definitely come up and talk to them.
Because of that, a lot of times, they make a mistake,...
...they get the wrong person.
So, when a foreigner comes up and talks to you...
...and you don't know who they are...
...just tell them, "You've got the wrong person", okay?
Okay. Today's Maestro Menu...
You've got the wrong person.
I took you for someone else.
Oh! I took you for someone else.
Okay. Maestro Lines.
Excuse me, are you John?
Oh! You've got the wrong person.
Oh I'm sorry, I took you for someone else.
Okay, that's it for today.
Now next week, there'll be more contents for you to enjoy...
...to become the native maestro. So, please watch.
And I'll see you next week!
Bye-bye!